[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
t'as pas les codes ou plutôt vous n'avez
pas les codes
c'est cette réflexion que m'a balancé en
pleine tronche le bras droit d'un grand
dirigeant
c'est très peu de temps j'étais en
colère
pour être tout à fait sincère ça valait
vraiment qu'on travaille je vous
expliquer pourquoi mais déjà avec ces
cinq mots c'est l'opportunité de mettre
n'importe qui sur le banc de touche et
lui dire qu'à un moment précis où il se
trouve il n'aura pas sa place là où il
est avec ces cinq mots ça avait beaucoup
contrarié mais j'ai besoin de rembobiner
pour vous raconter pourquoi la
génération vhs qui est sur place c'est
le moment avoir embobiné parce que j'ai
besoin de vous dire où j'ai grandi j'ai
grandi à evry on va être très clair on
parle des vrilles et pas d'ivry je sais
que c'est une lettre près mais quand
même je parle au celsa evry c'est une
ville à 30 km à vol d'oiseau 10 mhz pour
être tout à fait sincère j'ai jamais vu
cet oiseau d'ailleurs pour ceux qui
veulent se rendre à evry c'est plutôt et
regarder mais on a l'occasion d'en
reparler
pour les enfants venus d'evry je le
sentiment que longtemps on a été mis sur
le banc de touche envoyer vers les voies
de garage
très jeune et on va dire ça a commencé
très tôt j'étais pour les profs ce qu'on
appelle le mauvais élève
vous savez l'espèce de kit parfait du
mauvais élève mauvaises notes retard
insolent enfin tout ce qu'un prof
refusent ou redoutent d'avoir à ses
côtés très tôt aux cm1 je crois que ça
va pas je suis en échec scolaire
ma mère décide de rencontrer un de mes
profs la chose qu elle lui répond
anthony il rêve
je crois que j'ai tellement rêvé que
j'ai redoublé deux fois j'en avais pas
forcément rêver mais à l'époque c'était
l'échec scolaire
la deuxième chose ça a été ce problème
personnel que j'ai eu avec l'écriture en
fait j'étais proche de l'illettrisme
sincèrement c'était des zéro sur vingt
pointé la dictée tout le temps j'ai eu
un prof génial un jour qui a eu l'idée
de noter avec des notes négatives
ça m'a donné un 20 sur 20 enfin moins 20
sur 20 ça met en confiance
et là c'est un peu moins drôle mais
quand vous doutez de vous vous êtes
mauvais élèves et qu'en plus de ça c'est
l'orthographe qui pèche c'est
l'engrenage
surtout dans une ville de banlieue ça va
très vite les mauvaises fréquentations
on vous voit plus beaucoup aller à
l'école et là c'est le destin qui vous
repêche temps en temps en tout cas très
rapidement je vois un conseiller
d'orientation
hélas pour lui c'est très clair j'aime
la cuisine
ce sera un c ap cuisine il avait décidé
pour moi c'est ap la patrouille me
rattrape c'est ma mère elle se dit mais
anthony tu veux faire de la cuisine mais
assez ap un bep c'est vraiment ça en
fait
ma mère me dit un bep et un bac pro
après une école de cuisine
peut-être qu'un jour tu pourrais devenir
chef étoilé qui sait c'est vrai avait
peut-être raison la maman en tout cas ce
que j'avais vu chez ce conseiller
d'orientation c'est que quand vous êtes
en échec scolaire
vous êtes en échec tout court à ce
moment précis je m'accroche
c'est dur j'obtiens le bac je vous
promets que ce jour là mes parents y
croyait plus que moi il était tellement
heureux bon je lui au rattrapage
mais je suis quand même franchement ce
n'est pas une mauvaise nouvelle va
commencer une nouvelle quête celle de la
recherche d'emploi je cherchais une
alternance maman m'avait dit anthony
faut que tu ailles voir ce que c'est
qu'un grand groupe
alors je me dit vas-y on va chercher ça
un peu comme un warrior je me mettais à
envoyer 100 cv sans cv une réponse
négative
pas la joie à l'époque la formation dans
laquelle j'étais étaient connectés avec
une association d'égalité des changes
nous dit bon on va essayer et tant qu'à
faire
l'association m'appelle bonjour anthony
on a reçu votre cv et vous avez tout du
profil qui peut être discriminé nom à
consonance étrangère pas d'expérience
sur le cv ou pas de grands groupes et
vous êtes dans une ville de banlieue
pour pas vous mentir
j'avais l'impression que c'était une
publicité mensongère mais en fait je me
suis dit comme un truc qui fait maigrir
rapidos je vais le prendre
on verra bien ce que ça donne et là je
me dis bon petit miracle les portes d'un
entretien s'ouvrent deux entretiens
seulement je suis recruté je suis
recruté à paris les portes de paris
s'ouvre à moi je vous jure pour un jeune
de banlieue j'avais l'impression d'avoir
cassé tout ce qui arrive est trop
content hélas très vite mon enthousiasme
s'estompe
je me retrouve avec que des gosses qui
ont été cooptés par papa par maman je
suis perdu je perds confiance en moi je
sais plus ce que je fous là pour être
tout à fait honnête
la deuxième année d'alternance sera
fatale je tombe dans un groupe où mon
successeur me dira anthony ont appris
pour la racaille cheveux rasés costume
trop grand
je me rends compte que je suis pas à ma
place j'ai pas les codes
il ya un truc qui pêche je m'accroche à
nouveau et vous savez sur votre parcours
vous croiser des gens ces espèces de
petits anges gardiens que vous croisez
dans votre vie à l'époque c'était ma
prof d'espagnol anthony mais il faut que
vous testiez le celsa voulait faire de
la communication si votre cv votre école
a choisi elle croit en moi il faut que
j'essaye bon je tente
je tente les cris du celsa redoutable
vous le reconnaissez et lors de l'écrit
bon je me pointe vraiment jogging
baskets concours anonyme grand public je
m'en fous un peu comme dans l'ombre
je croise un collègue d'evry où elle
chante aux biens ou coincées ça dit quoi
et je me dis finalement n'étaient que
deux à 1 peut sembler un peu perdus ici
bref j'obtiens l'écrit petit miracle
je me pointe à l'oral cette fois-ci
chaussures pour costume c'était parfait
et là encore une fois j'avais pêcher
tout le monde était en jean baskets je
me suis dit j'ai rien compris à l'enfer
bref il me manquait encore les codes et
la bonne nouvelle je suis acceptée au
celsa paris-sorbonne
hu est alors la différence je les ai vus
très rapidement j'envoie 13 cv je le
remets en mode warriors il faut
j'obtienne un job
j'envoie 13 cv et devinez combien
d'entretiens de recrutement 13 premiers
entretiens louis vuitton wahou
j'avais toujours eu beaucoup de respect
pour cette maison une grande maison je
passe les trois entretiens et là je me
retrouve face aux drh europe pour une
alternance bon stressé évidemment mais
je sorte cet entretien et je me dis une
chose je pense que j'ai réussi
j'étais confiant vous savez c'est le
petit moment qui vient juste après
l'entretien à vous dites c'est bizarre
j'ai pas de réponse encore alors je
relance relance et je tombe sur cette
terre âge qui voulait me faire confiance
et elle me dit un peu en catimini
écoutez anthony je suis désolé mais ça
va pas le faire je dis mais pourquoi ça
enfin j'ai l'impression que ça s'est
bien passé
il vous a pris pour un menteur un
menteur je me rappelle avoir couru dans
les rer d à aller rechercher tous les
papiers tout scanner mais est pris pour
un mythomane
à vrai dire à 23 ans j'avais déjà créé
une start-up j'avais plusieurs livres
sur le cv en plus il était à peine signé
donc je pouvais même pas les montrer
bref il a peut-être de quoi me prendre
pour un mytho on vous pousse encore
pendant dix ans pendant dix ans je vais
me prendre des claques dans la gueule
je vous promets c'est ces petites
humiliations du quotidien parce que vous
n'avez pas tout à fait les codes pendant
dix ans je vais galérer
mais j'ai eu trois chances qu'ils sont
venus sur mon parcours
la première c'est que j'ai une maman des
parents qui se sont arrêtés
voir ma mère en fait qui s'est arrêtée
de travailler juste pour pouvoir m'aider
au quotidien la deuxième c'est ses
mentors j'ai eu la chance de croiser sur
ma route
ces petites personnes qui un moment
comprennent que n'est pas tout à fait le
bon logiciel ca
est pas fonctionné comme il faut mais
qui vont vouloir vous aider j'ai deux
potes jean et jacques togolais sénégal
est étudiant à la fac d'evry et qui
avait juste envie d'une chose c'est que
j'ai mon bac
ils m'ont aidé en maths mais c'est comme
ça que j'ai eu et la troisième est
évidemment c'est cette association
d'égalité des chances
mozaïk rh à l'époque qui m'ouvre les
portes d'une boîte parisienne
nous sommes le 12 novembre 2016
les trente ans frappe à ma porte et je
m'étais fait une promesse de choper un
gros job à responsabilités fait que ça
suppose de casser beaucoup de barrières
mais ce jour là le 12 novembre 2016 je
suis nommé directeur général adjoint
d'une grande maison publicité wahou
quelle fierté
quelle confiance on m'avait donné là
nous voilà en posture de manager un peu
comme vous savez à la playstation
on vous file la manette c'est à vous de
jouer bah là c'était le cas g 20 mai 20
consultants dans mon équipe qui viennent
des plus grandes écoles de france et je
suis là en position de manager
évidemment à ce moment là c'est une
grosse responsabilité
je navigue dans le monde des patrons
mais je prends conscience aussi que à ce
moment là tout s'écroule
je suis dans un monde figé en fait le
monde dans lequel je navigue le nouveau
monde des patrons est complètement figé
où sont les femmes
où est la diversité que j'ai connus evry
où est la diversité sociale où tous sont
toutes ces personnes des frères et soeur
de coeur qui se battent au quotidien
qu'on pas forcément les codes mais qu'on
potentiel où sont ils
[Applaudissements]
je me rends compte à ce moment là pardon
je me mens je me rends compte à ce
moment là que je suis riche très riche
riche mais je te là où j'ai grandi
[Applaudissements]
ça me donne un pense vous l'avez compris
à ce moment là je me rends compte que je
suis riche mais riche de quoi riche de
là où j'ai grandi de la diversité
culturelle de la diversité sociale
ethnique de cette diversité dans
laquelle j'ai grandi je suis riche de
pas avoir eu un truc super facile je
suis riche à ce moment précis d'avoir eu
un parcours compliqué alors je décide de
casser le game en fait je me dis je peux
pas rester ici c'est impossible il ya
trop de choses à faire il ya trop de
gâchis
je me dis il faut que chose quelque
chose à l'époque avec une copine de
promotion on décide de monter un
mouvement ce sera un mouvement d'égalité
des chances
je décide de même quitté la boîte dans
laquelle j'étais qui va m'accompagner en
fait à ce moment précis je décide de
faire de l'égalité des chances mon
combat parce que je ne veux plus jamais
plus jamais qu'en france
quelqu'un qui est sur le banc de touche
quelqu'un qui galèrent quelqu'un qui n'a
pas les codes se sont en exclusion par
rapport au monde du travail
je ne veux plus jamais que en raison
d'un âge d'un genre de votre orientation
de votre handicap de votre couleur de
votre différence que vous sentiez exclus
du système
je veux plus jamais qu'une personne
française
un talent français doute d'être français
alors ce combat il va il va prendre la
forme d'un mouvement d'égalité des
chances le 27 novembre 2017 ont fait une
scène une scène où il ya sept talent sur
scène sept talent qui viennent parler de
leur parcours
il y en a deux qui m'ont complètement
une claque la première s'appelle loubna
elle a décidé de faire de la cuisine en
enjeu d'inclusion et faire en sorte que
la cuisine pour plein de mama en france
serait un objet d'inclusion le deuxième
s'appelle mail vie melvin melvin a
grandi à grigny c'est un petit frère de
coeur pour le coup
melvin passe autant de temps à apprendre
les maths dans son quartier qu'elle est
enseignée un vrai héros
bref vous l'avez compris uppercut gauche
droite
je décide de tout quitter et de ne plus
être ici bref vous souvenez de cette
patronne dont je vous ai parlé
vous savez ce que je lui ai répondu je
dis que c'est pas parce que j'avais pas
les codes c'est parce qu'à ce moment
précis j'ai pas eu envie de les utiliser
alors ce soir
si j'avais un appel il serait à toutes
ces personnes chômeurs chômeuses
stagiaires apprentis personne sur le
banc de touche personnes qui doutent de
leur place dans la société à tous les
mauvais élèves à toutes les personnes
qui se sentent de temps en temps au trop
souvent sur le bas de côté sur le
bas-côté pardon vous n'avez pas les
codes et si on les casse est ensemble
merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]